the girag an experience antes de que
passaa de lo que pasó con mucha before
what happens rather mm-hmm that's what
happened every time well he saved me
that's it because we let's explain what
happened you got a hold of a tainted
supplement there was something in the
supplement that it was that it was in
the supplement so you got clear no you
had a small seafood is suplement amando
person what I know and believe me I
understand what happened hmm
they say there's a know of it because
this Superman I take it right I take it
why this supplement
I have something forbidden in it yeah
why why no before right well it's very
common and a lot of times what happens
is the suppliers when you say if you're
a supplement company and you have
someone make some stuff for you and then
you package it and sell it the people
that are putting it together for you
they're selling a bunch of other things
too and oftentimes things get into your
supplement they're not supposed to be
there especially again no Tim supernet
la gente que hacen lo Porto a la
compañía Mia but oh ho ho ho compañía
para boa - Pablo - whom - yeah haciendo
Papa Tom being people save me yeah yeah
yeah hey cone Tom you know this has
happened to a lot of guys is it true are
you going to GNC and buy [ __ ] that could
get jacked yes
GNC yes I've heard you talking on the
podcast not when I'm on with other
people yeah so I could go into GNC and
think guys a lot of stuff that you go if
you go into GNC you'll buy stuff that's
on the shelves for a little while then
they pull it and when companies sell
stuff to them sometimes they'll say
there's one thing in it but there's
other things in it as well that's a real
common thing especially if something
works really well like a lot of times
the stuff that works really well people
find out yeah it works really well cause
it's [ __ ] steroids in it yeah you
could mean might not notice be GNC just
any vitamin store
not necessarily GNC but there's a bunch
of legal steroids at GNC vitamin shop at
Walmart more yeah see this is very very
common when you and you go to these
places and buy these things there's a
lot of stuff at a regular vitamin store
that'll make you test positive buy you
sada you'll test for banned substances
from stuff you just buy in a store go
you know many times I think before after
that they do this happened I think in
many time invitation people from Cuba
take it people say ok you and you you
you you come to Cuba mm-hmm for maybe 20
days I wanted the people see because the
genetic for Cuba off the charts
no for the no for the athletic people no
no normally everybody normal people
right right
you need to see see right and open mind
right right man he know that's it what I
say well you need to pay for the soup
for the Reuters right come on man they
don't have the money
come on man right come on people don't
have don't have anything I know you're
saying the other thing is you can take
all the steroids in the world you're not
gonna look like you the way a person
like you looks it has to be genetics
what up - ah what's up where might that
been to party you know polycystic amor -
you take a regular there are genetics
he took a regular guy and gave him
steroids he would never look like you
she took old people that's what I meant
- the method steroid no Sara Palace I
come up there thank you
yeah a lot of it is genetics and a lot
of it is also you got to think from the
time you were little you were involved
in this intense athletic program your
body developed that way good eating
yeah
they get to the hole in co2 tower I got
to get to a quick / - you sassy yo
pocket mocha to toss in don't say it all
say no I wanted no believe me I want to
do this
the invitation people from Cuba wanted
them people see right yeah you want them
to go serious yeah I wanted to I want to
see and I want to see after after no no
because it's my secretary for day for me
you know I wanted after the wing I
trained there they when I bit in the
barrel mm-hmm because you know can put
it everything what you do it and the
video what the people say I do this is
this and now it can beat him you
understand would say yes okay I wanted
the invitation camera for me for three
months for three months I never taken
nothing and now you see what I do right
you understand yeah stop talking [ __ ]
right understand so people accused you
of taking steroids
after the tainted supplement thing but
you've never tested positive before no
never or after III do for for the
Olympic Commission mm-hmm that's the the
main oversee internal in the single from
95 he's been testing for the Olympics
tested by the Olympics I'm sorry right I
know and never he never came a positive
you know the thing is what someone looks
at you because you have so much muscle
they assume you're doing something well
no bleep immediately selected people
stomach in the winter in the fury okay
Tommy Randall now gente piensa
do it nothing ISM yeah the people say
will they smoke this file the people
think that if you're doing that
[Applause]